important qu'on n'a jamais dit et c'est
la première fois qu'on le dit aucun
appel de votre alors dites-nous du doubs
c'est un truc vous n'avez jamais vu
jamais on n'a jamais parlé
la question pour vous attention où vous
mangez vous répondez grichka avez vous
déjà eu recours à la chirurgie
esthétique sur un coup au visage
moi je réponds très facilement vous avez
dit non déjà mais oui je maintiens
non mais non je vous dis pas ce qu'ils
ont fait des expériences ce héros par
nos expérimentations ses expériences
commenté piccini lompret un bec bunsen
frères des tubes du vide a plus plus
sainement et s'adonner à ça mais c'est
vrai non seulement non mais c'est vrai
comment non mais parce que voilà comme
ça au moins ça ne leur pose et plus
aérée démission c'est clair voilà donc
tu as répondu et en fait j'ai fait des
expérimentations
c'est à dire c'est alors des maires de
toiles à la merde alors non mais il est
très bon il trouvera toute façon une
manière si tu veux de la france
l'expérimentation quoi pas du tout en
réalité ce qui nous est ce qui nous a
été imposée il ya longtemps nous étions
c'est la vérité la vérité aussi d'accord
du tout massachusetts etats-unis et les
gens trouvaient qu'on se retrouve et on
se ressemblaient beaucoup mais même trop
alors tu sais que là bas on se demandait
tous si on était en face de gens qui
nous demandent est invariablement je
sais pas du tout lequel ressemble le
plus à l'autre par exemple une des
questions
d'accord alors oui c'est ça mange pas
frères
oui par les français parce que la
science est venu [ __ ] un bordel là ce
qui s'est passé parce que ça
s'intéresserait tout le monde se demande
jeudi les on dit la vérité
non mais nous a demandé de jouer dans
une publicité faite aux états unis
d'accord qui devait d'abord deux
objectifs 1 nous distinguer l'un de
l'autre et deux et ça c'est le point
important qu'on n'a jamais dit et c'est
la première fois qu'on le dit si bien la
france qui en appelle d'autres
[Rires]
alors dites-nous didot
je suis un truc vous n'avez jamais vu
jamais on n'a jamais parlé à l'isi cela
dit voilà vous avez des personnages des
personnages mystérieux oui c'est vrai
que vous interrogez de savoir d'où vous
venez
quel est votre origine est en fait ils
ont dit mais on va accentuer et c'est
vrai qu'on s'est vus sur toutes les
affiches là bas et dans tous les réseaux
venant d'une autre planète ah ouais mais
non mais c'est vrai ce que je dis
j'espère que mes seins denses ne voulut
voilà ils ont voulu faire croire que
vous veniez d'une autre planète le
nouveau que nous venions d'un autre
monde en accord est donc pris donc ils
ont fait une des expériences ils ont
fait oui enfin je peux parler des
détails mais c'est tout c'est absolument
vrai d'ailleurs aux états unis mais
c'est ouf
oui et donc ils ont dit voilà vous venez
d'une autre planète
oui mais c'est vrai c'est une question
qu'on nous pose régulièrement et il n'y
a pas plus tard que quelques jours on
m'a demandé jeudi la fnac et là
quelqu'un vient vers moi
le monde des petites et répondez moi
franchement kwh est donc vous n'êtes pas
d'ici moi je lui ai répondu de façon
assez naturelle
écoutez si si si je vous répondais et si
je vous disais qu'on vient d'ailleurs
ouais est ce que vous me croyez pas oui
sûrement
1 alors écoutez je ne vous dirai pas ah
ouais c'est ça qui est repartie aller
chercher des dons qu'ils ont voulu faire
croire aux techniques venus d'une autre
planète dont ils ont fait des
expériences ou ça vous ne l'avez jamais
dit m antonius jamais
[Rires]
des expériences et quads et elle pose
les vraies questions tout va tirer un
moment donné est ce qu'une expérience
des landes quelque chose alors bien là
rien n'y a pas de corps étrange juste
non benneteau adrian simplement des
expérimentations sur des rayonnements
en fait c'est à dire abonnements se sont
longuement de gamme des longueurs d'onde
qui sont plus ou moins pénétrante en
fait
ah oui et donc qui donne qui donne est
victime en ce moment d'aider on peut
dire des épisodes conférence est ravi
des interférences états unis ça qu'ils
ont fait c'est bien entendu et c'est aux
états unis que ça s'est passé c'est ouf
les médias l'ont très longtemps et vous
n'avez jamais regretté ces expériences
aux contres mais vous avez servi de coma
est en fait aux américains oui c'est ou
balassa pas trop bouger
[Rires]
jeffrey des années c'est pas ça à face à
reste stable 1 saison un succès de
malades et ne vivent pas sur la tête de
ma mère c'est un truc de ouf
les lego games quoi je te lis ça ils
n'ont pas depuis trente ans ils ont la
même taille mais on a un truc de ouf
c'est ton x moi les gars quoi certains
mais seraient pas merci en tout cas
parce que grichka nous a répondu à cette
question que palm monde se pose est une
manière très claire
[Musique]